[Applaudissements]
madame la première ministre après mon
rapport sénatorial de 2019 qui alertait
déjà sur le déclin de la production
agricole française favorise en même
temps l'entrée toujours plus grande de
produits agricoles importés qui ne
respectent pas nos normes après
l'épisode de koh vide qui nous a fait
prendre conscience de notre dépendance à
des produits faits à l'autre bout du
monde est dans le même temps nous à
faire recoudre découvrir l'intérêt
majeur d'une alimentation produite en
france après l'entrée en guerre de la
russie contre l'ukraine faisant flambée
des prix jamais égalés les matières
premières agricoles ce qui nous rappelle
l'intérêt majeur de disposer d'une
agriculture forte et protégés après nous
avoir fait croire que vous aviez
récemment compris tout cela en nous
vantant par exemple les bienfaits des
clauses miroir en rebaptisant le
ministère de l'agriculture en ministère
de la souveraineté alimentaire
comment en ayant dit et vu tout cela
pouvez-vous ne pas vous opposé aux
accords de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et la nouvelle-zélande